so this is the dominant form again here
I'm able to drive him in but I feel he's
got a desire to come back towards me as
he does I Circle his hand and squeeze
his elbow and wrist together this is
applying the goio here it's folding his
wrist in as he feels this he dislikes it
and kind of turns his back to me as he
does that I straighten this out and
drive the Goku here so I'm driving
through his shoulder into his shoulder
from his wrist and drive this down I
drop the inside knee here from this
position I have a lot of Leverage so I
drive again into the goo when he Taps
right now he's stopping the form because
there's a lot of pain in the wrist but
he might also try to pull his arm in so
e he pulls his arm in I catch it against
the mat here and push the elbow down we
get two Goos in
there one more time at
speed